[Musik]
hey lieben wir machen heute ein video
mit drei denn ich zeige euch drei snacks
für euren nächsten gelungenen filmabend
und das ganze in zusammenarbeit mit
kerrygold und ich quatsche gar nicht
lange drum herum ich starte jetzt mit
einem absoluten verriet rezept nämlich
einer nacho soße
dafür benötigen wir den original
irischen chada von kerrygold in der
herzhaften variante außerdem
paprikapulver edelsüß etwas sahne ein
spritzer essig milch und etwas tabasco
hamza und ich wir sind ja so richtige
filmfreaks wir gehen immer ins kino und
auch immer wirklich die dann wenn die
premiere läuft damit auch bloß nichts
verpassen
aber ich gebe ehrlich zu ich mag das
auch einfach auf der couch zu liegen im
pyjama und dann einfach meinen eigenen
filmen zu machen
und weil ich immer team nacho bin mache
ich jetzt wirklich meine natur soße
immer selber und ich kaufte mir auch
schon gar nicht mehr und ich habe jetzt
hier mein topf auf dem herd aber in
herten noch nicht einschalten das machen
wir erst wenn alle zutaten im topf sind
und ich starte jetzt mit milch und sahne
gibt das schon mal rein und reibe dann
meinte keese in den topf
[Musik]
und ich habe den käse damit er sich
einfach gleichmäßiger in der soße
verbinden kann und ich benutze wirklich
am liebsten den original irischen
chatter von kerrygold weil er ebenso
geschmacksintensiv ist weil er sechs
monate reichen durfte und weil er eben
so eine wunderschöne farbe hat und das
alles auf ganz natürliche weise also
ohne künstliche farbstoffe
jetzt noch die restlichen zutaten in den
topf geben und dann ganz wichtig ganz
langsam erwärmen also nicht auf kochen
sondern wirklich auf mittlerer stufe
erwärmt und dann ist die virtual soße
eigentlich auch schon fertig
[Musik]
und nach dem abkühlen wird die macho so
richtig schön cremig aber jetzt finde
ich meine lieben muss etwas kitschiges
her
wir machen jetzt die cracker und dafür
habe ich eh die zutaten auch schon
bereitsteht
ich verwende wieder den original
irischen chatter von kerrygold wieder in
der herzhaften variante dann habe ich
hier meinen paprikapulver edelsüß etwas
backpulver und milch sahne butter und
salz und pfeffer so ihr lieben jetzt
schnappt ihr euch eine große schüssel
und vermengt alle genannten zutaten in
dieser schlüssel zu einem teig nimmt
dafür ganz einfach eure sauberen hände
und den käse den jetta auch gerne wieder
rein reiben dann vermengt er sich
einfach viel besser mit den restlichen
zutaten
[Musik]
nach wenigen minuten habt ihr einen
schönen festen teig der aber noch
ziemlich weich ist und da werden ja
nachher ausstechen muss er für eine
halbe stunde in den kühlschrank dann
kann man das einfach viel besser
ausstechen und ihr habt einfach gar
keine probleme dafür nimmt ihr euch
jetzt einfach frischhaltefolie und
drückt den teig so ein bisschen flach
damit ihr diesen kühlungs prozess
beschleunigt wir können gut an und dann
sehen wir in einer halben stunde wieder
[Musik]
nach der kür zeit nehmen uns den käse
teig und rollen einmal auf der
arbeitsfläche aus nehmt euch am besten
ein nudelholz und dann nehmt ihr euch
ein ausstecher eurer wahl ich nehme
jetzt den hier also das kann jeder
beliebige sein stich teure schellack
wecker aus und gibt sie auf ein mit
backpapier ausgelegtes backblech
[Musik]
der teig wird jetzt noch mit einem
verqualmten eigelb bestreichen und dann
mit sesam bestreut ihr könnt es sesam
auch gerne schwarzkümmel nehmen
[Musik]
und jetzt meine lieben backen wir die
trecker im vorgeheizten backofen bei 200
grad ober und unterhitze für zwölf bis
15 minuten
[Musik]
weiter geht's mit rezepte nummer drei
untersten blätterteig kletterstangen und
dafür brauchen wir auch nur wenige und
überschaubaren zutaten die ich hier
vorbereitet haben diesmal nämlich den
original englischen chatter in der
variante wird sich das in scheiben
außerdem habe ich hier blätterteig ich
habe jetzt hier tief repeater teig
einmal auftauen lassen
basilikum der ist getrocknet dann habe
ich hier noch zum bestreuen
schwarzkümmel und sesam etwas
tomatenmark zum bestreichen und für die
schöne farbe ein eigelb jetzt habe ich
hier die hälfte des klettersteigs auf
einer arbeitsfläche gebe da tomatenmark
drauf das könnt ihr ganz einfach denn
verstreichen und darüber gebe ich dann
getrockneten basilikum und es gibt so
einen leckeren geschmack und wir das
denn habt dann gebt ihr die täter
scheiben da drüber und dann sind wir
auch schon fast durch also das hier ist
echt ein witz rezept
[Musik]
so wenn du dann hier angekommen seid
nehmt ihr euch einfach euren blätterteig
und gibt den obendrüber das heißt ihr
verschließt das ganze und dann teilen
wir jedes päckchen quasi in drei
strenger und erhalten insgesamt 9
[Musik]
jetzt schnappt ihr euch jeweils einen
strang und zwiebel stehen an den enden
immer in die entgegengesetzte richtung
und dann erhaltet ihr so ein hübsches
muster und gibt es schon mal auf eure
mit dem backpapier ausgelegtes backblech
jetzt werde ich die stangen noch mit dem
verkohlten alge bestreichen und gibt da
sesam und kreuzkümmel oben drauf und
dann wandern sie auch schon in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
und unterhitze so lange bis sie richtig
schön goldbraun sind
[Musik]
im vorjahr fertig sind die blätterteig
kletterstangen und jetzt müsst ihr mir
mal verraten welches rezept euch am
besten gefallen hat
hamza die wirtschaft so dass ich wusste
das aber im gigawatt opfer nehmen ja das
kind echten blitzschnell für gebraucht
das war halt echt so eine sammlung an
mit rezepten die recht während des
filmabends genießen könnt schreibt mir
doch mal was ihr lieblingsfilm ist
welchen ihr immer und immer und immer
wieder sehen könnte also meiner ist
total ich wenn ich ehrlich bin schreibt
so gerne ich mich zuerst mal durchlesen
ich mal gespannt
und ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel
freude beim nachmachen schaut in die
video beschreibung für die genauen
mengenangaben und dann freue ich mich
wenn ihr auch beim esp rezept video
wieder einschaltet
[Musik]